time to talk medicare annual enrollment
with southwest medical the sponsors of
this next segment rocky caught up with
one of their doctors to learn more
dr izayanilu welcome to las vegas now
oh thank you it's my pleasure to be here
yes we are talking about medicare of
course it is that time of the year so
let's just start with the basics what
does
medicare annual enrollment period mean
wow so
medicare annual enrollment is your time
to be able to enroll or make changes to
your medicare plan
if you already have a medicare advantage
health plan you can switch that
you can select a primary care doctor
from local providers and if you had just
medicare this is the time to change as
well
it started far back in october 15th and
it's going to end around december 7th so
the optimum care network of nevada and
southwest medical
invite you to choose a healthcare plan
that provides the care you need when you
need it what is the difference between
medicare advantage and regular medicare
i know this gets very complicated for
people so break it down original
medicare is normally divided into
various parts and each part covering
either the doctor outpatient visits or
in hospital care but a medicare
advantage covers everything medicare
does but in addition to that they're
actually able to cover things like
vision dental prescription benefits um
and really according to a report from
medi better medicare alliance and people
with medicare advantage actually save
tons of money compared to original
medicare on the average
and they are often healthier
with the added bonus of having their
health vision and hearing covered as
well
okay and what are some of the health
resources that you have available with
the optum network
so southwest medical has always been
passionate about helping older adults
we've done this for nearly 50 years in
our community and we are a proud
provider group to the optim care network
of nevada so when you have the right
medicare advantage plan you have access
to
more than 3 000 local healthcare
providers here in the valley
under the optum care network of nevada
and you have access to all the valleys
major hospitals so that that way you get
the right care at the right time
okay and when people are watching this
at home and they're like wait i have
more questions where should they go what
should they do
well this is your time to enroll and
make changes and it started october 15
and it's ending december 7th there's
going to be a number flashing on your
screen um call that number and you'll
get in touch with a licensed sales agent
from the optim care network of nevada so
they will help you choose the plan that
is right for you okay well thank you so
much for everything you do for our
community
thank you
thank you to southwest medical
associates for sponsoring this segment
they have several locations across
southern nevada give them a call 702 608
for enrollment information or you can
visit smalv.com
las vegas